all right we ran into one of those days
where i was like all right day off
spider-man no way home trailer
got to get to work which i love talking
about because it's spider-man i know i
didn't do a video on the eternals
trailer the answer is simple it's
because it's spider-man dude eternals i
don't know enough about the eternals to
contribute to the conversation
spider-man spider-man trailers batman
trailers superman trailers always be
there for those are my early comic book
characters right there man they're near
and dear to the heart so we have a new
trailer and only trailer to spider-man
no way home at one point there was a
rumor that there wasn't even gonna be a
trailer i was like that's sweet i hope
that's real alas it's not we have a
trailer that dropped it because i guess
the trailer leaked online because
everything leaks online which i feel
like even talking about this trailer i
should give a spoiler warning for
spider-man far from home if you haven't
seen that movie this is spoilers because
this
just takes place after that all right
you've been warned after spider-man far
from home but he was framed for murder
mysterio got his last laugh which i
don't think there's any way mysterio's
actually dead because he's mysterio
anyone can fake their own death it's
mysterio
and elvis
and tupac that's where this movie starts
out it shows that his life is completely
it's like if his life was a board game
table like risk or monopoly someone just
went
flip the table happens in every game you
ever play in either of those two games
and the game of life if you're you know
peter parker spider-man so you see the
point of the movie the plot come into
focus when he visits doctor strange and
peter parker's like can you manipulate
reality where people just never learned
that i was spider-man benedict wong is
like don't you do it dr strange you're
the sorcerer supreme what would tilda
swinton do and maybe it's a larger
conversation that they do have but it
looks like doctor strange was like don't
worry peter that benedict might not do
it but which benedict has two thumbs and
is totally gonna [ __ ] the multiverse
this guy oops look like we screwed the
multiverse which he does say the
multiverse is something we know
frighteningly little about which does
make sense since the multiverse only
just started existing in their world
however peter parker in this scene does
show the difference between being
intelligent and being smart i mean peter
parker's intelligent he's always
intelligent all the peter parkers i've
seen are pretty intelligent people but a
smart person when the sorcerer supreme
is like all right i'm casting a spell
that manipulates the multiverse and he
tells you to shut the [ __ ] up because
you're ruining the spell a smart person
would be like i'm gonna go ahead and
shut up i'm gonna take a knee it's it's
fine sorcerer supreme told me to shut
the [ __ ] up so that's what i'm gonna do
but not this peter parker he just keeps
prattling on and then oops screwed it
all up intelligent but not very smart so
that's what they're dealing with they're
dealing with the multiverse of madness
before it becomes the multiverse of
madness it's just no way home but the
real the money shots the reason we tuned
into this because the rumor's been like
oh doc ock's gonna be in it jamie foxx
electro's gonna be in it willem dafoe's
gonna be back in it as green goblin you
see the doc ock arms it actually shows
alfred molina and he's like
hello peter but the couple thoughts i
have here are we don't see the green
goblin we do hear his cackle his laugh
fan of the first spider-man movie
absolutely fan of willem dafoe's green
goblin but his helmet his mask always
bothered me and since we don't see him
at all i'm hoping he has a bit of a
redesign like give him a face that
actually looks like the green goblin's
face if they make him look more
goblin-ish and doesn't just look like a
helmet i think that'd be pretty cool but
my other thought is when doc ock shows
up and he's like
hello peter my first thought was when he
showed up he should be like
who are you you're not peter parker
because peter parker looks like that not
you
who are you but and i saw this comment
in the comment section as i was still
processing this and i was like oh that's
a that's a legit theory is that he's not
talking to tom holland though the
trailer's cut together to make it look
like he's talking to tom holland the
thought is he may be talking to toby
maguire because one of the rumors out
there is that tobey maguire andrew
garfield and tom holland are all in this
movie as spider-man's that would make
more sense that he would call toby
maguire peter parker because he would
know him as peter parker granted in
spider-man 2 also spoilers for the
original spider-man 2 just being
cautious right after he found out that
peter parker was spider-man he went down
he's like i will not die a monster bam i
guess this isn't a continuity in the
multiverse where that didn't go down
like that there are some things to look
forward to in this movie man i'm looking
forward to it i'm a little bummed out
that that whole cliffhanger of like oh
the world knows that peter parker's
spider-man how is he gonna deal with
that it looks like it does eventually
get forgotten but it is the driving
force that does lead into this
multiverse adventure but now that we're
moving on to the multiverse thing and
they got alfred molina's got coming back
[Music]
phone call while i'm filming
i always put your phone on silent when
you're filming or in a movie theater but
now that we have villains from other
spider-man movies coming back i can't
deny that i'm like oh yeah that other
thing would have been cool to see but i
really want to see how they do that
looking forward to the movie it was a
good trailer side note i know i get a
lot of comments like when you're going
to review spider-man 2 there's this
comment this person's like attempt
number what are we up to 30 something 40
it's a lot it's like attempt number x to
get jeremy to review the original
spider-man 2. you don't need to do that
i'll do it before this movie comes out
my short thoughts um it's one of the top
tier comic book movies of all time and
definitely the best spider-man movie
ever made those are my quick thoughts
alright the trailer to spider-man no way
home have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you